surprise it's your favorite comic book
character and you had no idea they were
coming but which superhero cameos were
the most surprising of all
the 2021 3 cool Spider-Man no way home
was packed full of guest stars and
cameos the third MCU Spidey movie
brought back an array of characters from
previous films all played by their
original actors such as Alfred Molina as
Dr Octopus Willem Dafoe as the Green
Goblin and JK Simmons as J Jonah Jameson
but arguably the most surprising Cameo
was that of Charlie Cox's Matt Murdock
following the abrupt cancellation of the
Netflix Daredevil Series in 2018 fans
were not optimistic about the prospects
of Cox returning to the role after three
years with no news it seemed more likely
that Marvel would cast the new actor
rather than bring Cox back yet when no
way home hit theaters there he was
advising Peter Parker on his tricky
legal situation it was a cameo many fans
had dreamed of but few saw coming not
long after the release of no way home
Marvel announced that Cox would be
returning once more in a brand new
Disney plus series Daredevil born again
meanwhile fans appetite for more
Daredevil was satiated with a handful of
guest appearances in She-Hulk attorney
at law this guy really kind of doing it
for me in 2016 Deadpool shocked and
delighted audiences with its
over-the-top graphic violence and
Charming knack for vulgarity the movie
also featured X-Men stalwart Colossus
who tries and fails to convince Ryan
Reynolds titular Merc with the mouth to
join the iconic team of mutants while
many fans were probably hoping for more
X-Men characters to cameo in Deadpool 2.
you probably expected it due to the
decidedly adult nature of the series
nevertheless the studio successfully
kept one major Cameo appearance under
wraps and this time it's not just one
actor who turns up out of the blue it's
an entire team James McAvoy Nicholas
Holt Evan Peters Ty Sheridan Cody Smith
McPhee and Alexander ship all appear
briefly as their respective X-Men
characters it seems like a lifetime ago
now but when Iron Man first hit theaters
in 2008 cinematic universes were a
far-off dream in just about everything
in the movie felt fresh and new from the
charm of beleaguered actor Robert Downey
Jr to the high-flying visual spectacle
of the armored hero himself audiences
were blown away by how inventive the
film showed itself to be and there was
one cameo in the film that almost nobody
expected one that came for the very
first time after the credits rolled a
post-credits scene that set a new
standard for stinkers the moment sees
Samuel Jackson make his Marvel debut as
super spy Nick Fury emerging from the
Shadows Fury lays the foundation for the
groundbreaking superhero Team Up The
Avengers despite leaks suggesting that
this Cameo was in the cards Marvel did
an excellent job of throwing fans off
the scent tossing out rumors of a cameo
from Hillary Swank and omitting the
scene in press screening of course even
those who saw it coming could never have
imagined the future he'd create Henry
Cavill was one of the first actors cast
in the DC extended Universe he first
played Superman in 2013's Man of Steel
before returning for Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice and Justice League then
for a while cavil seemed to totally
disappear from the dceu leading some
fans to worry that he would not be
returning to the role for future movies
Flash Forward to 2022 when it was
announced on the eve of the release of
Black Adam that Cavill was to wear the
cape once more it turned out that Dwayne
Johnson had used the star power to
convince Warner Brothers to bring caval
back into the fold beginning with a
brief Cameo at the end of his film Black
Adam
should talk teasing a future showdown
between Johnson's anti-hero Powerhouse
and cavill's Man of Steel this scene
appeared to be the perfect setup for an
epic sequel unfortunately all this went
up and smoke pretty much as soon as
writer director James Gunn was placed in
charge of the new DC Universe gun opted
to wipe to slate clean and start fresh
in 2023 he cast David goren sweat as the
new Superman by 2021 Marvel was on a
roll with their cameos and the MCU was
consistently delivering surprise
appearances in each and every new film
in eternals they dropped one of the
biggest yet Global music star Harry
Styles and prior to the movie's release
in November 2021 pretty much nobody had
any idea it was coming based on the
comics of the same name eternals
introduced a team of immortal beings who
have lived undetected on Earth for
centuries each with their own unique
superpowers they come together to
confront a race of deadly creatures
known as the deviants with a roster of
major stars on the cast list there
wasn't any real need to add another
famous face yet the movie's post credit
scene gave us one regardless Styles
played Eros in his brief appearance in
eternals a character better known to
fans of Star Fox though the scene seems
to suggest a bigger role for the
character there's been no hint of a
future appearance since will Star Fox
return or is he destined to remain a
mere footnote in MCU history only time
will tell
in Black Panther wakanda forever Michael
B Jordan reprized his role as Eric
killmonger the villain who previously
attempted to take wakanda's throne in
Black Panther following the tragic death
of black panther star Chadwick Boseman
the sequel pivoted its story to Center
on King t'challa's sister shuri as she
takes on the mantle of the Black Panther
forced to confront her own destiny
Sherry finds herself in the ancestral
plane where the spirits of the Dead
wakandan leaders now reside anything
could have happened here John Connie's
King tachaka could have made another
appearance or Marvel could have
attempted some digital trickery to
include the late Bozeman instead wakanda
forever went for the ultimate rug pull
bringing shuri face to face with
wakanda's greatest enemy even better
killmonger's Cameo actually plays a key
role in affecting shuri's character Arc
as he urges her to pursue a violent path
of bloody revenge on the enemies of
wakanda more than anything though it was
a real treat to see Jordan return to the
role he played so well ever since the
MCU began fans have been suggesting
their own dream casting decisions for
their favorite superheroes and when
Marvel announced that the Fantastic Four
or we're getting the reboot treatment
under the MCU Banner the most popular
choice to play Mr Fantastic was the
office Star John Krasinski well Marvel
was listening loud and clear in the
studio decided to give fans their dream
come true with a cameo from the actor in
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse Madness
hello Stephen fantastic board didn't you
guys chart in the 60s it wasn't quite
what fans really wanted and of course as
this version of the character was from
an alternate timeline but Krasinski
showed up as Mr Fantastic nonetheless
much of their Chagrin however there was
no larger plan for kazinski to reprise
the role in the new Fantastic Four film
in this read Richards is swiftly killed
off during a battle against the Scarlet
Witch still the fact that Marvel paid
homage to one of the biggest fan casting
Rumors in recent memory stands as a
testament to the Studio's appreciation
for its audiences
John krasinski's appearance as Mr
Fantastic wasn't the only cameo in
Multiverse of Madness though since the
film's trailer gave away the return of
Patrick Stewart as Professor X the next
most surprising Cameo probably came in
the form of Anson Mount as the inhuman
leader Black Bolt Mount had played the
character on TV once before marking one
of the few bright spots in the
short-lived in much derided 2017 ABC
Series in humans that series was so
poorly received by fans however that
nobody ever expected Marvel to reference
it again
when the doctor strange sequel debuted
mounts brief and gruesome returned to
the Black Bolt role came as something of
a surprise in more ways than one
the DC EU was built with a grand plan to
spawn countless sequels spin-offs and
team-up movies when Ben Affleck was
first cast as the Caped Crusader for
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice the
studio intended for him to return in a
movie of his own one that Affleck would
direct while a Confluence of factors led
to that project ultimately being
scrapped it was originally thought that
Affleck's Batman would face off against
Joe Manganiello as the deadly Sharp
Shooting assassin Deathstroke to get the
ball rolling director Zack Snyder
decided to include the actor in the
final post-credits scene of 2017's
Justice League although it appears that
just Sweden changed it slightly when he
took over the film
scene also brought back Jesse Eisenberg
as a bald-headed Lex Luthor who enlists
the services of the mercenary
Deathstroke in an effort to take down
Superman and his new gang of Super
Friends to put it plainly
shouldn't we have a league of our own
sadly the mixed response to Justice
League helped Usher the dceu towards its
untimely fate leaving this scene as just
one of many teases that will never be
followed through in this era of
cinematic universes and endless
multiverses it's easy to expect
superhero movies to deliver surprising
cameos as a result audiences have gone
used to seeing one fellow hero dropping
in to pay a visit to another
however in Thor Ragnarok director taika
waititi did something a little different
enlisting the services of one of
Hollywood's biggest stars for an
uncredited walk-on role in a memorable
moment early in the film Thor arrives
back home on Asgard where a group of
theater actors is putting on a stage
performance of Thor and Loki's
Adventures playing thorus Chris
Hemsworth's brother Luke while Odin is
played by Sam Neal who had previously
worked with YTD on hunt for the Wilder
people but the biggest and most
secretive Cameo was none other than Matt
Damon as Loki while insiders managed to
spoil this Cameo beforehand which tends
to happen a lot nowadays it would have
no doubt been quite the shock for any
audience members who weren't aware of it
beforehand
unexpected cameos are fun enough when
they're an award-winning Megastar or
beloved fan favorite character returning
after a long absence but it's something
else entirely when a cameo offers a good
old-fashioned Head trip such was the
case at the conclusion of the 2019 film
Shazam after a rousing family-friendly
superhero adventure that saw Zachary
Levi and Mark Strong duking it out as
colorful comic book adversaries the
post-credits scene introduced one of the
wackiest villains in comic book lore the
evil worm known as Mr Mind in this scene
the villainous Dr Savannah sits in a
prison cell after his diabolical plans
are thwarted by the movie's hero through
the bars of his cell Mr mine arrives to
propose the two team up this was
unexpected enough for fans familiar with
the character but it's hard to overstate
how weird it was for those who weren't
one of the wildest cameos in any recent
Blockbuster superhero movie Mr mind's
appearance garnered plenty of Praise
from DC fans but those same excited
moviegoers were disappointed when the
film's sequel didn't include him as the
next big bad relegating him again to a
small post-credits Cameo appearance
damn it after Marvel got its Multiverse
rolling with Multiverse and Madness and
no way home DC attempted to outrun them
with 2023's the flash the film sends the
Scarlet Speedster across multiple
alternate realities and timelines
uniting him with Batman who is played by
Michael Keaton for the first time since
1992's Batman Returns but that's not all
the flash is filled with a bevy of blink
and you'll miss it cameos including
archival footage in CGI Recreations of
the likes of Adam West Christopher Reeve
and Helen Slater one of the cleverest
cameos in the movie is the appearance of
Nicolas Cage who finally gets his chance
to play the Man of Steel 25 years after
he almost starred in the Doom's Tim
Burton film Superman lives the closest
he ever came to donning the blue and red
spandex was in a screen test for the
late 90s project but now fans have
finally been given a proper glimpse of
cage in the role in a further nod to the
hardcore fans Cage's Superman does
battle with an Infamous giant mechanical
spider that was said to be at the heart
of Kevin Smith Superman lives screenplay
when Barry Allen goes looking to change
the course of history in the flash he
seeks the help of Batman first it's Ben
Affleck then Michael Keaton but there is
still one more version of The Dark
Knight that makes an appearance in the
movie following his Multiverse Adventure
The Flash returns to what he thinks is
his own reality only to be confronted by
a different version of Bruce Wayne this
time though it's George Clooney who
played the Caped Crusader in the reviled
1997 movie Batman and Robin Clooney's
return is remarkable not just because it
was a surprise but because of how hated
he was when he first played the role
Batman and Robin Remains the lowest
rated Batman movie on Rotten Tomatoes
and is regularly ridiculed by fans and
critics alike the fact that the studio
would bring the actor back and remind
audiences of one of the biggest failures
in the character's history is quite
something but that Clooney agreed to do
it even after admitting how bad his
Batman movie was takes it to a whole new
level following director engle's
ill-fated attempt to bring Hulk to the
big screen in 2003 Marvel decided to
reboot the character from the ground up
they also decide to work this relaunch
into their new Cinematic Universe the
second MCU movie The Incredible Hulk hit
theaters in the summer of 2008. the film
attempted a more serious gritty approach
to the tale of the Hulk this time
featuring Edward Norton as Bruce Banner
battling with his angry Alter Ego Banner
goes on the run from General Thaddeus
Ross who has created a monster of his
own coming mere months after the release
of Iron Man the film found itself hot on
the heels of an unexpected smash
sensation Marvel decided to leverage the
overnight popularity of Tony Stark to
help bring viewers into the Incredible
Hulk calling upon Robert Downey Jr to
appear in the movie's very last scene at
the end of the movie Tony Stark arrives
to console a recently defeated General
Ross and casually tells them they're
assembling a team of Heroes not
dissimilar to Samuel L Jackson's
appearance at the end of Iron Man though
perhaps intended to tease The Avengers
Marvel mostly ignored General Ross's
involvement in this early phase of the
MCU later a Blu-ray exclusive One-Shot
mini movie called the consultant
explained why Stark had approached Ross
in the first place if we want the
general not to refuse this request then
we have to send someone who will truly
annoy him good old Tony Stark the first
X-Men film featured the first big screen
Cameo from Stan Lee in a Marvel movie in
which he played a hot dog vendor on the
beach the standout star of the film of
course was Hugh Jackman the Aussie
newcomer whose turn as Wolverine made
him an instant star every subsequent
X-Men featured Jackman in a starring
role until 2011 when the franchise
rebooted with X-Men first Class still
director Matthew Vaughn found a fun way
to include him in the party set decades
before the first X-Men first Class
introduces a whole new cast of
characters as well as some familiar ones
now played by younger actors this
includes James McAvoy and Michael
Fassbender as Professor Xavier and Eric
lencher together the two mutants embark
on a journey to recruit New Mutants to
their fledgling superhero team in one
particularly surprising moment Xavier
and lensher walk into a bar and before
they can ask anything to the Surly cigar
chomping Logan they were buffed with
quite the expletive though it's only a
momentary Cameo with Jackman delivering
just three words of dialogue it carried
along his unbroken streak of appearances
in X-Men films one that would only end
with 2019's dark Phoenix though many
fans still see X-Men first Class as a
reboot it was really more of a prequel
after all they brought back Hugh Jackman
first Cameo as Wolverine rather than
recast him altogether and he wasn't the
only one either more than just a nod to
Prior franchise continuity The Cameo
comes when Jennifer Lawrence's Mystique
attempts to seduce Michael fassbender's
Magneto Magneto makes an offhanded
remark about her being too young and as
quick as you can say Rebecca remain she
morphs into the model turned actor who'd
already played Mystique in three
previous movies the transformation lasts
only a moment but it's one of the rare
times when Romaine got to play the
character in her natural appearance free
of all the blue body paint for which the
character is so well known Romaine goes
on credited for her appearance but no
true fan of the X-Men films missed this
Cameo which paid due respect to the star
who helped make Mystique one of Marvel's
most popular villains Perfection after
three X-Men movies it became decidedly
clear that Hugh Jackman was the star and
that the character Wolverine was the
real draw for moviegoers with that
knowledge Fox decided to ditch the rest
of the team and give the fans what they
really wanted a number of movies all
about Logan
though the first X-Men Origins Wolverine
wasn't so well received its sequels made
for a huge Improvement the studio even
used 2013's The Wolverine to help set up
a separate X-Men sequel to do it they
surprised audiences with an appearance
from both Patrick Stewart and Ian
McKellen back in the roles of Professor
X and Magneto the two renowned actors
returned in the film's post-credits
scene in which Logan makes his way
through an airport there he's confronted
by Magneto who wants Logan's help to
face a dangerous new threat Logan is
surprised to find that the villain is
accompanied by none other than Professor
X who convinces him to join their cause
but no one was as surprised as the
audience who had no idea the solo
Wolverine sequel would end with the
lead-in to X-Men Days of Future Past
following his critically acclaimed
horror Thriller the Sixth Sense director
M Night Shyamalan brought us the comic
book inspired movie Unbreakable Bruce
Willis played David Dunn a security
guard who realizes he has superhuman
abilities and uses them to take on a
twisted terrorist named Mr glass though
there was much talk of a sequel after
the release of unbreakable nothing came
of it and Shyamalan soon moved on to
different projects then in his 2016 film
split fans got the shock of a lifetime
when Willis made a cameo as done in the
story's final moments in this
eye-popping reveal Dunn is seen sitting
in a diner watching news footage of
James mcavoy's character the Beast
confirming that split was in fact a
sequel of sorts to Unbreakable a full
Trilogy would be completed three years
later 2019's glass United Willis Jackson
and McAvoy in a three-way Showdown for
the Aegis one of the greatest cameos
that Marvel ever bowled off came
courtesy of writer director James Gunn
who made his Blockbuster movie debut
with Guardians of the Galaxy in 2014. at
the end of the movie's credits we're
taken back to the smoldering Rebel of
the collector's domain previously a
veritable Treasure Trove of Easter eggs
much of his precious collection is
ruined but one prize specimen decides to
stick around and get in a few quips
Howard the Duck this mischievous Mallard
was last seen on the big screen in
1986's Howard the Duck which is widely
regarded as one of the worst comic book
movies ever made how would you really
are the worst foreign
for some reason the idea of a
wisecracking space duck never really
resonated with audiences though the
character in the comics has always been
a cult favorite among a certain segment
of the fan base James Gunn it seems was
one of them his decision to include
Howard provided a delightful
acknowledgment of Marvel's strange
history and proved just how weird the
comics can get and what better place to
include him than in the movie with the
violent raccoon in the Talking Tree
Howard would later appear in cameos in
both Guardians of the Galaxy sequels
Avengers end game and an episode of the
animated Disney plus series what if and
you know what they say when you're out
of luck always go duck I'm pretty sure
no one says that oh they say it really
totally created in 1938 Superman may
have the longest history of any
superhero on screen his first on-screen
appearance came in the early 1940s as
the star of the iconic Fleischer Studio
cartoons Superman entered the world of
live action in 1948 in a series of movie
serials starring Kirk Allen he has since
been played by a number of different
performers with more set to take the
reins in the near future this long and
storied history has allowed actors from
past Superman stories to Cameo from time
to time and in 2006's Superman Returns
longtime fans spotted a very important
one indeed at the beginning of the film
were introduced not just to Lex Luthor
but also the wealthy Widow he married in
conned out of her Fortune the woman is
only seen for a moment but a true
Superman fanatic may have recognized her
face that's because Luther's wife is
played by none other than Noel Neal who
starred opposite Kirk Allen as the
original Lois Lane in the 40s and
Superman Returns wasn't her first Cameo
either she appeared as Lois Lane's
mother Ella in 1978's Superman the movie
as well as the Super Bowl TV series in
the late 80s
in 2015 Marvel Studios released Ant-Man
a new franchise addition to the MCU
starring Paul Rudd as the miniaturized
hero Scott Lang considering how obscure
the character had been in the greater
pop culture Zeitgeist up to that point
you might be surprised to learn that
this wasn't the first time he had been
seen on screen unofficially Ant-Man also
made a brief TV appearance back in the
late 70s and the MCU movie pays tribute
to this with a cameo from the actor who
first played the part of the Incredible
Shrinking hero that original Ant-Man
harks from way back to 1979. when
Saturday Night Live featured a sketch
called superhero party
a present for you what
sketch Superman and Lois Lane host a
cocktail party with guests ranging from
The Flash and Hulk to Spider-Man and The
Invisible Woman all played by various
SNL cast members among the more famous
comic characters at the party was
Ant-Man played by original series star
Garrett Morris audiences may have
forgotten the first live-action
appearance of Ant-Man but director baton
Reed didn't and he cast Morrison the
role of a confused cab driver for such a
small hero that Cameo pays some huge
respect to the man who is technically
the world's first Ant-Man
everyone knows that Edward Norton wasn't
the first actor to play Hulk on screen
Eric Bana portrayed him in the 2003 film
Hulk while Lou Ferrigno starred in The
Beloved 70s TV series Ferrigno appeared
briefly in The Incredible Hulk in which
he played a security guard he also
voiced The Hulk himself but one other
Hulk actor showed up in the Incredible
Hulk Paul Soul shows up in a small role
playing a kindly old man at a pizza shop
who helps Norton's Bruce Banner hide
from the government you would be
forgiven if you didn't recognize Souls
as he was never actually seen on screen
as the Hulk in fact Souls was the first
actor to ever play the role of Bruce
Banner on screen voicing him in the 1966
Saturday morning cartoon Marvel
superheroes as it stands his part in The
Incredible Hulk wound up being the
second to last film in his career as
Souls passed away in 2021
[Music]
thank you